hello everyone and welcome to Bobby
Fisher's first ever recorded game uh it
comes as a suggestion from from several
subscribers throughout the years uh but
I just never got around to it and I
really was interested in uh what what
was Bobby Fisher's first ever recorded
game because I had no idea and what I
found was uh very interesting and I I
was the most impressed by not only the
game by but but by his opponent uh
gentleman Dan e Myers and now uh I'm
just gonna read you a small part of his
obituary and I will put a link to it in
the description below the first thing
you will see is a link to his entire
obituary uh it was made by the
shakaguchi society International Chicago
Society he was the president of this
society and uh this is uh shakaguchi
flute uh it's a made of bamboo and it's
a it's a very nice instrument as I
understand uh but uh just listen to this
small part
um so after graduation with a degree in
geology from University of Arizona in
1944 Myers was drafted into the U.S army
and he was assigned to work at the
Manhattan Project in Los Alamos while
there he developed an interest in Magic
after studying at Harvard Myers set off
on what would become a lifetime of
traveling during a business trip to
Europe he met his wife Barbara and they
moved to Mexico with their were the
first children were born in 1958 they
moved to England and it was there that
Myers embarked on creating a unique
Wilderness Garden called Lorien with a
vast collection of azaleas and
rhododendrons from all around the world
now this is sorry not that this is Lori
and this is what they talk about
individual it sort of I imagine as I
understand uh from from reading about it
some sort of a
Tolkien themed house you know something
or maybe Hobbits would live but in real
size I didn't really do any research on
it but so it was it's supposed to be in
that style and these are the flowers
that they are discussing the azaleas and
the rhododendrons so I mean pretty
pretty wild stuff and uh also uh they
mentioned that apart from chess then had
many other interests and passions he was
successful as a distributor of emeralds
and amethysts from Africa he was also an
Aficionado of the Japanese shakuhachi
flew to that that we've shown and became
the president of the international
shakuhachi Society obviously that's why
they uh posted his obituary very
extensively after his wife Barbara
passed away he moved to spend his final
years in the Sun Valley but continued
playing chess to the end of his life in
1996 he won the British senior
championship and in 2004 he won the U.S
Senior Championship just the days before
he passed away he was competing in the
North American open at bali's Casino
Resort in Las Vegas so basically he
played chess his entire life and he
played chess in the moment he died so uh
that's uh who uh Fisher's opponent is in
this game also he had a black belt in in
Judo and he's uh as I'm I mean I only
read this obituary but he does appear to
be a most remarkable individual so do
check it out it will be the first link
in the description below might um get
you more uh hyped for the game and also
understand the the well the the result
of the game so let's check it out and uh
it's also well known that the Bobby
Fischer uh faced the king's Gambit only
two times in his life in this game here
the first game he ever played the Blitz
game against Denmark in 1953 and the
second game he uh ever uh played in The
King's Gambit as black was against the
Boris passkey in 1916 Margo Plata I
covered that game I was about a year ago
I think I covered it six years ago and
then I did a remake like a year ago uh I
will put a link to that also in the
description below as the these will be
the only two games where Bobby faced the
king's Gambit so the second link in the
description below is a video to his game
versus Boris passkey do check out out if
you haven't but maybe check out this one
first so let's see what happened Dan
opens with E4 and Fisher replies with
Ponte E5 in 1953 here Bobby was nine
years old he still wasn't 10. so Ponte
F4 going for the king's Gambit e
captures an F4 and now not Knight to F3
but Bishop to C4 this is The Bishop's
Gambit second most popular way of um uh
dealing with the e-captors on F4 and now
Knight to F6 fish are not interested in
Queen Tage for check because uh well it
is just a sub optimal Knight to F6 is
much better and okay in the days of
morphine Anderson this was played quite
a lot but nowadays okay King F1 and you
really have nothing Knight F6 Knight to
F3 and now white will happily uh
challenge the the black queen with
pretty much every move he makes and gain
free Tempe so after Bishop C4 we have
Knight to F6 by Fisher Knight to C3 and
now Pawn to C6 with Pawn to D4 and now
Bishop to B for Fisher uh pins the
Knight and puts pressure on the E4 Pawn
so Pawn to E5 and now Knight to E4 and
now Queen to H5 there's something
definitely worthy of a of a Blitz game
threatening Checkmate and now a modern
Grandmaster would play a D5 he would uh
give up a pawn temporarily here just
Castle to safety and then later on you
could pick up that pawn whenever you
want uh but okay if you've played
castles uh still a valid idea Knight to
E2 and now we have Pawn to D5 now he
goes for it with Bishop back to B3 uh
but not putting your Bishop on D3 is
weird to say the least but B3 uh it's
hard to say what what that Bishop will
do there for for the rest of the game
but okay G6 by Fisher we have Queen to
H6 and now
uh okay you you should play something
like F6 but it's a Blitz game you you
have to remember that and in those days
you had no increment so it's probably a
five plus zero so you should play
something like a F4 and then once a
white recaptures on F4 you should play
Rook F7 and even give up on F6 and then
just continue development because you do
not want to be behind on development but
in the game Fisher played Bishop to G4
and now comes Bishop to D2 again not the
greatest move by by Myers But Here Comes
Knight captures on D2 King captures on
D2 and now Fisher should just play
Bishop captures on E2 the the Knight
cannot move so you have to capture with
the King and now F6 you're gonna bust
open the center and go after that white
king I need you but Fisher played Pawn
to G5 and it's weird uh to see that pawn
to G5 is black in the king's Gambit is a
mistake or a blunder because it's a
standard move you play you play e
captures and F4 you accept the king's
gamut and then you play G5 uh defending
that F4 Pawn it's um is the the the most
standard way to play The King's Gambit
with black but here it just doesn't work
because of a very specific idea from
White and that is Ponte H4 okay Fisher
knows that Dan will open up the H file
go after the H7 Pawn but he has his
Bishop he's just gonna put it on F7 and
F5 go to G6 maybe and defend the H7 Pawn
however uh here G captures an H4 uh
Bishop F5 right away also isn't all that
spectacular because after characters in
Bishop G6 there's Knight captures on F4
and now how do you deal with Knight
captures and Checkmate uh you can play
Bishop to E7 it's a very tricky idea
Knight captures on G6 now is impossible
because of Bishop catras and G5 with a
beautiful Fork here forking the king and
the queen but still uh White would be
much better you would ring The Rook into
the game you would artificially Castle
Queen side and white would be better but
this was definitely the way to go uh
facial played G captures on H4 and now
comes Rook captures an H4 Bishop to F5
now guarding the the H7 Pawn here but
now just Rook a to H1 and here Fischer
played Bishop to E7 and now uh
incredible as it is then Myers has a
winning idea against the nine-year-old
Bobby Fisher so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Dan while I
give you a couple of seconds
foreign
to do it congratulations on spotting any
of the winning moves because there are
plenty of them but this one is
absolutely crushing and this is what the
damn played so congratulations to
everyone who found it and that is Rook
the G4 check this is what Bobby missed
because now Bishop captures is
impossible due to Queen captures and H7
Checkmate so naturally he played Bishop
to G6 but now comes Queen captures on H7
and this is not Checkmate as the bishop
cannot move so uh Fisher's ever first
recorded the game is this this is for
the first ever recorded game it's a
Blitz game against the king's Gambit and
he just got uh absolutely destroyed he
he played a I mean he played a great
game for uh for a nine year old and up
until the point where he played the G5
he was uh crushing it he was much much
better here but after G5 he just allowed
this attack and he couldn't bounce back
but it's absolutely amazing that the two
games Fisher played the only two games
Fisher ever played uh as black again the
king's Gambit is this one and the one
against the Boris passkey in Marvel
Plata 1960 and he lost both of them so I
mean uh Fisher is Fisher but King's
Gambit is quite an opening uh I'm sure
you'll agree so do check it out if you
haven't second link in the description
below is this game against sposky also
an incredible game uh uh like I said do
check it out but yeah and also do check
out the obituary by the ashakaguchi
society about Dan Myers a lot about his
life that that's interesting so do check
that out as well but yeah incredible guy
he like he he really did everything in
life including defeating Bobby Fischer
like I mean you can't you really can't
complain uh yeah and that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it first ever
recorded the game by Robert James Fisher
I would like to thank Paul hinemun
doitran ravishing reptiles YouTube Mike
Wagner and uh third dreams for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on you
wonderful suggestions such as this one
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day